so we're already seeing it it's about to
get much worse there is going to be a
corona virus vaccine disinformation war
that is going to make the measles
vaccine disinformation seem like child
child's play and we're already seeing it
Bill Gates conspiracy theories
conspiracy conspiracy theories that the
corona virus itself was a man-made plan
to create a pretext to give everybody a
vaccine so you can you know the insert
your conspiracy theory sterilization
population control whatever I'm not
going to give you every example but
we've seen it all and we now have as I
told you earlier very encouraging
developments on a number of new vaccines
and most recently from moderna moderna
announcing in an early trial of their
vaccine everybody who got the vaccine
generated antibodies at or greater than
the level that a natural corona virus
recovery generates Phase three set to
start in July all good news but
meanwhile the corona virus vaccine
disinformation war
he's already scaling up before we get
the vaccine we are going to have virally
spreading propaganda about the vaccine
there's the stuff in that bogus
documentary plan Demick from a couple of
weeks ago you've got a lot of
pseudoscience around coronavirus already
5g conspiracy theories tied to corona
virus you've got the president wondering
about injecting bleach and Lysol doctor
foul he pulled into all sorts of
conspiracies and on and on and on and
there's a really good piece in the new
york times by kevin ruse which suggests
this is just the beginning of the
propaganda fight around the corona virus
vaccine he says there will be a very
loud movement that is going to try to
convince the public that the eventual
coronavirus vaccine or vaccines are
dangerous they are lethal they are bad
for you they are a menace they are part
of all sorts of horrible conspiracies
involving governments or elites or Bill
Gates or whoever and the important thing
to understand is that they only need to
convince some people to potentially
prevent heard immunity and they only
need to convince some people to create
absolute havoc just look at what they've
done with measles and the outbreaks that
have been caused over the last few years
we know that this is going to happen
particularly because of the urgency of
this vaccine so we know we may have
shortened observation period
surveillance periods for people who have
received the vaccine and we would do
that safely in the sense that it would
be done with vaccines already proven to
be safe the question would be well
normally you might want to confirm that
the vaccine gives you immunity for a
year after six months we might say
listen it gives six months of immunity
let's start giving it to people that is
going to be used by the anti-vaxxers to
argue it's not been tested the the
testing has been short-circuited
short-circuited is a wild experiment so
that's one layer that we can expect
number two we know that to really
produce the vaccine at scale and get to
billions of doses organizations like the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation will
almost certainly have to be involved
they are already the targets of anti VAX
activists and they've been the targets
for a long time sometimes it's Bill
Gates wants to profit from the vaccine
sometimes it's Bill Gates wants to
control the population with a vaccine
and then number three is Kevin Roose
points out we might have a period after
the vaccine is available where airlines
might say listen to fly with us you need
a certificate of vaccination this would
not be a govern government mandated
vaccine it would be a private company
like JetBlue might say our rule is for
safety we require a vaccine certificate
this will explode in the anti-vaxxer a
vaccination has been one of their
talking points for a long time now of
course vaccinations if you want to fly
JetBlue is very different than the
government is forcing everybody to get a
vaccine so the point is this is going to
be a fight and it's going to go beyond
the normal recesses of the internet you
know we're used to natural medicine
websites and this sort of thing doing
anti vac stuff but my prediction is that
the coronavirus anti vax propaganda is
going to have wider distribution than
just those enclaves on the internet so
what we need to do and what Kevin Roose
says in his New York Times article needs
to happen is that the pro vaccine
movement which
all science and medicine needs to
mobilize now science about vaccines
needs to be disseminated and in our
system being proactive is rarely
rewarded being proactive is rarely done
so I'm skeptical that there will be any
such coherent effort but it's important
that it be done and we're going to
continue doing it
hey Monday we've got a huge Memorial Day
membership special the show is going to
be off on Memorial Day what with
coronavirus since we're all just stuck
at home we've not had an off day for
something like four months or so or even
longer we are taking Monday off we are
going to do a one-day Memorial Day
membership special it's gonna be an
unconscionable discount attorneys
general are beating down my door saying
David don't do it it's too big of a
discount but we're gonna do it anyway to
be notified about this great membership
discount on Monday Memorial Day just get
on our mailing list sign up for the
mailing list at david pakman.com we'll
take a quick break let me know what you
think about the vaccine trials and
propaganda on Twitter where you can find
me at des Pakman